Starry night socks and a gun that shoots
ketchup onto your food.
It's episode 22 of LÜT.
First, let's break the ice... or let the ice
do the breaking itself as a hammer.
Of course, this hammer lets you open bottles.
When you pour out the contents, be sure
it's into a pint glass wearing a Batman
cape.
Pour some water into this fish tank, it's
cute and small and completely powered by your USB
port.
Hey look, pants. Scratch and sniff pants.
The fabric literally has raspberry
perfume scent capsules baked
into it, which break when scratched
releasing the smell.
Now if you hate pants, don't wear any.
Don't even wear a skin for that matter.
These leggings look like your muscles.
If you're going to be apart from you
love on Valentine's Day, send them a kiss
with Kissenger.
Two robots connected wirelessly,
so that when you kiss one,
the other robot relays that
kiss so the other person feels it,
wherever they are.
ThisIsWhyImBroke.com features
amazing things. For instance,
brake light decal masks to make your
brake lights look like this.
On Amazon, I also found a Superman,
tropical fish
hibiscus flowers, skulls, or this
really literal one.
They also have "Word as
Image," a fun book that uses the letters
and words to suggest what the word means.
For instance: vampire, smile,
clock.
You can see more words like that
and see them animated by following a link to
video in this video's description where
links to everything
can be found.
When your dog fetches
this ball, it'll look like he's got a big
old flappy tongue. They're
currently out of stock, but this one
isn't, which when held in a dog's mouth,
gives it a moustache. If you're looking
for great gift ideas, try doing the
opposite. The worst gift ever.
This fun little package literally contains
nothing
but socks and underwear.
More exciting is disney couture.
An oversized castle ring or a double-ring
that puts all the dwarves on your hand.
If you like your accessories more practical,
try out some working thermometer earrings,
a compass necklace or some Phillips head screw
earrings.
Ouchie Wow Wow! Piranha Plant earrings are
always a good idea, but you can keep it
8-bit with Mr Dandy's
pendants asteroids.
Or this one, he calls not Pac-man,
but Pukeman. Have a ball while snuggling
with your soft plush
testicle or ovary or bladder
or brain or intestines or anatomical
heart. For more heart shaped items, let's
talk heart-shaped
umbrellas, paper clips,
a warm heart-shaped hot water bottle
or these measuring cups on FredFlare
who also carry a neat bed of
tulips USB hub,
a frog you add water to to get yourself
a prince, a map of the world
to scratch off where you've been,
a log to rest your head on -
don't worry it's a pillow - and the only
thing your hamburger phone
really needs...
French fries flavored lip balm
Oh, NeatoShop also has hearts stuff, like
an anatomical heart
pencil holder.
They'll also provide balloon animal
book ends. A zombie cupid figurine,
a devilish skin for your iPad or a snap
suit for your baby that says
"ipood." Before it was poo, it was cake
served on a high heel shoe,
but if you want something darker,
check out Despair Inc's
BitterSweets - candy hearts that say things like
"So so alone," "Aging poorly"
or "Dog is cuter."
This special fabric dye
is sensitive to light,
so you can mix it up, paint it on a shirt
and then leave it in the Sun to develop
actual photographs from negatives.
Oh, and that fashion hanky in your shirt pocket?
It can be
a notepad.
Sushibooties let you wear sashimi
as slippers.
They also carry fortune cookie baby booties,
a nunchuck pillow and for the baby
a nunchuck rattle.
This is Naomi Kyle's autograph.
You can't
have this one, but for more awesome
things you can buy online,
check out her show on IGN's new channel, Start.
The whole channel's great and she goes
in-depth into awesome things you can
actually
own. And unlike LÜT, they actually give
away some of the stuff they cover
to lucky viewers.
So go check that out...
And as always,
thanks for watching.